Німецький концерн Rheinmetall - один з найбільших оборонних концернів у Європі.
Він спеціалізується на виробництві великокаліберної зброї та снарядів до неї
і має запрацювати в Україні.
Компанія вже підписала угоду з держпідприємством "Українська оборонна промисловість"
про створення спільного виробництва.
Йдеться передусім про виробництво боєприпасів для західних систем,
особливо в артилерії. По-друге, мова йде про те, щоб у довгостроковій перспективі
розглядати, яким чином українська армія може перейти на західні системи озброєння в цілому.
На першому етапі планується технічне обслуговування та ремонт транспортних засобів,
переданих Збройним силам України Німеччиною, а на наступних -
спільне виробництво окремих видів продукції Rheinmetall в Україні.
Одна з основних переваг наявності такого заводу в Україні - це близькість до лінії фронту.
Зброя мусить потрапляти до військових якнайшвидше, наголошує Вольфґанґ Ріхтер.
Звісно, з будь-якого хабу, як їх називають, чи центру, що знаходиться на польському
чи словацькому кордоні, з Заходу на Схід проїхати з цими танками чи запчастинами,
звичайно, важко. Треба подолати відстань у 1000 кілометрів.
Це все має здійснюватися залізничним транспортом з вантажівками.
І якщо все це можна зібрати докупи - покласти в одну руку компанії,
яка має велику частку у виробництві, як от, наприклад, Rheinmetall, тоді це має сенс.
У березні Rheinmetall анонсував, що планує будівництво в Україні танкового заводу
приблизно за 200 мільйонів євро, який би випускав до 400 танків Panther на рік.
У липні концерн заявив, що відкриє завод з виробництва бронетехніки на заході Україні,
який випускатиме й ремонтуватиме близько 400 бронетранспортерів Fuchs.
Проєкт вигідний для України, адже вона почне відновлювати свою
виробничу інфраструктуру, вважає офіцер служби Генштабу австрійської армії Маркус Райснер.
Якщо Україна зараз почне повільно відновлювати свої промислові потужності,
то це є дуже важливим знаком для її власних збройних сил, що вони здатні вирватися
з певного рівня залежності та також мають власні ресурси.
Утім, експертка з оборонних досліджень у Кінгз-коледжі Лондона Марина Мірон переконана,
що поки триває війна подібний проєкт реалізувати в Україні буде складно.
Я вважаю, це будівництво більш проблемним наразі, принаймні поки триває війна.
От якби ми говорили про часи після війни… Ми не знаємо, як буде розвиватися ситуація,
але це все дуже амбітно. Rheinmetall намагається виробляти танки в Україні,
можливо, дешевше, щоб служити європейським союзникам більше, ніж допомагати Україні.
Адже Україні потрібен бюджет, щоб купити ці танки. 400 танків не вироблять
і дадуть Збройним силам України просто так.
Це знову ж таки порушить питання вартості - навіть якщо вони дешевші,
ніж вироблені в Німеччині, хтось все одно повинен за них платити.
На початку листопада стало відомо, що Rheinmetall передасть Україні
100 тисяч боєприпасів до мінометів 120-мм калібру протягом наступних двох років.
Замовлення на постачання боєприпасів для ЗСУ розмістив уряд Німеччини.
Воно є частиною військової допомоги Україні на 400 мільйонів євро.
Президент Зеленський просив західні компанії інвестувати в Україну,
щоб підняти економіку країни.
І уряд Німеччини спеціально пропонує підтримку та безпеку тим компаніям,
які інвестують в Україну. Для Rheinmetall тут безпрограшна ситуація.
Навіть якщо щось піде не так, то для них все безпечно. На все є страховка.
Тож якщо цей завод буде знищений російською ракетою, Rheinmetall не втратить
на цьому гроші. І це ключовий момент. Багато чим в цьому сенсі вони не ризикують.
Попри переваги виробництво танків в Україні несе з собою багато ризиків.
Зокрема, і з безпекової точки зору. Робота підприємства в Україні,
територію якої постійно обстрілює Росія, передбачає розгортання надпотужної системи ППО.
Захід має надати підтримку передусім, підтримуючи ППО.
Тому що, якщо Україна не в змозі забезпечити свій тил, наприклад,
захистити від російських атак майбутні споруди, які там будуть створені,
то, звісно, вона не зможе вибудувати стійке виробництво.
Але якщо вона зможе це зробити, тоді українська промисловість зможе
виробляти ці бойові танки і потім застосовувати їх на фронті.
Те, чи краще будувати завод під чи над землею, на думку Маркуса Райснера,
питання другорядне, адже найважливішим щодо безпеки виробництва
експерт вважає винищувачі.
По-перше, має бути активна ППО, по-друге, пасивна.
Засоби активної протиповітряної оборони - це винищувачі.
Пасивна протиповітряна оборона вибудовується навколо заводу поетапно так,
щоб його неможливо було знищити. Найефективніший шлях - децентралізація.
Тож має бути не одне велике виробництво, а 10 маленьких місць.
Деталі можна об'єднувати, а потім доставляти на фронт.
І тут, звичайно, можна вживати і жорстких заходів, як от будівництво під землею,
наприклад, або в тунелі - залізничному тунелі. Звичайно, це можна було б робити.
Глава Rheinmetall Армін Папперґер сказав, що і після закінчення війни в Україні
не побоюється падіння попиту на продукцію. За його словами, у Європі та США
запаси боєприпасів на такому низькому рівні, що на їхнє заповнення піде найближче десятиліття.
Про будівництво заводу в Україні почали говорити ще у березні,
та коли оборонний концерн дійсно почне ремонтувати і виробляти техніку - невідомо.
Експерти допускають, що будівництво такого підприємства - це проєкт на перспективу
для допомоги Україні в майбутньому.
Звичайно, це довгостроковий проєкт, який не матиме впливу цього року,
можливо, вже під час наступної війни. Компанія Rheinmetall розробила новий
основний бойовий танк - прототипи вже видно, їх демонструють і випробовують.
Тоді цілком може бути, що Україна й надалі переходитиме на такі системи.
Я маю на увазі бойовий танк "Пантера", який тепер є новим доповненням до лінійки Rheinmetall.
Тож це був би один із способів підготувати українську оборонну систему до майбутнього.
Заявлений план про виробництво 400 танків - дуже амбітна ціль,
яку важко буде реалізувати під час війни, запевняє Марина Мірон.
Можливо, Rheinmetall сподівається, що війна колись закінчиться,
і цей завод допоможе Україні зміцнити обороноздатність і надасть їй шанс отримати ці танки,
а також ремонтувати українські "Леопарди" і, можливо, виробляти "Пантери"
та іншу бронетехніку. Тож я думаю, що це радше післявоєнний проєкт.
Інакше це взагалі не мало сенсу. Знову ж таки, гроші, які вони збираються інвестувати
- 200 мільйонів євро - здаються недостатніми для такого проєкту в Україні,
особливо зараз, враховуючи, що туди потрібні системи ППО та інші речі.
Україні не вигідна довга війна на виснаження. Чим довше вона триватиме,
тим більших руйнувань і людських втрат можуть зазнати українці.
Коли завод зіграє свою роль залежить від того, наскільки Україна зможе просунутися
в довгостроковій перспективі. Якщо вона зможе вести цю війну
в сенсі оборонної боротьби проти Росії, то цей завод,
звичайно, зіграє свою роль. Якщо ні, то буде надто пізно.